bah ça n'était pas un combat je me dis
suisse
tu connais mon jour page en baisse à
papa à moi si je reste non mais si c'est
chacun le sait comment on va bien sûr
vas-y mais tout comme le tien
je sais qu'un mémorial
[Applaudissements]
à plein temps mais déclaré attendais pas
jared jeunes j'arrive excusez moi je
débute
non mais là rien de rien alors qu'ils
bossaient tous les matchs commencent
comme l'étude c'est un ami à vous unique
est absolument oui
ah bon ah oui ça va c'est d'ailleurs je
fréquente mais non je ne veux pas me
croiser trois fois dans 20 ans en 45 ans
pour l'amitié c'est mais reconnaît qu'
il ya chez les artistes comme chez les
gays en un regard on se comprend mais
quoi vrai ou pas c'est un artiste
préposé donc des questions sur la
carrière de nos deux invités et sur leur
belle petite merde je vais venir
déféquer dans ton genre sachez
d'ailleurs voir défection en rien un sou
j'habite est juste à côté de la numéro
spécial bombes à bologne avenue robert
schuman série les chercher un extincteur
ouais ou cas où ces nouveaux
chroniqueurs se manifesterait de façon
négative je pense que ce serait pas mal
merci ben merci je vais en chercher un
safari
alors combien je présente je regarde
juste s'ils marchent marchent maintenant
mathieu tu sers notre côté
installez-vous pour la bt marie fugain
crise
mais que tel l'animateur de cette
démission
[Applaudissements]
les producteurs qui viennent allonger
limpide comme jamais le travail se fait
à la carte
il faut une fois ci d ouvrir les yeux il
reviendrait avec benjamin dans quinze
jours avec plaisir et tu sais qu'on
t'aime tu seras toujours bienvenu ici je
t'aime moi la force arrête avec 7 5
[Musique]
cette fois ci
[Applaudissements]